[Musique]
combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de pata
plus je ne vous trompez pas porter bien
sûr photo
ouattara parce que claude a d'ailleurs
il me manque un
[Musique]
voilà ce qui arrive quand on pose son
doigt pointe le matin j'étais méchant
bien méchant je t'ai fait un gâteau pour
toi tout seul pour tacle ou y moi je
t'apporte helibras que tu mènes merci
merci pâte à coeur merci pâte à tarte
je vais lire et manger dans le jardin je
suis très content
bobo
hé hé
mon gâteau lui en fait très plaisir
je sens mes livres qui nous ont fait
plaisir maintenant fais mon gâteau
pathak loup mange beaucoup et ne lit
jamais je n'ai pas ce que je vois je
suis sûr que tu mens gym à la première
balle est pendante oise et fenêtres
pathak ou monde et ne lit pas il fait
les 2 en même temps et tu ne l'avouera
jamais de ma main c'est en tout cas le
gâteau c'est moi qui l'ait fait tandis
que les livres ce n'est pas toi qui les
écrit c'est l'intention qui compte
mais attention c'est moins fatigant que
la cuisine c'est plus facile de
fonctionner n'importe quel gâteau que de
choisir un bon livre
en tout cas c'est moi la plus gentille
non c'est moi je te dis que c'est moi la
plus longue de d'accord
[Musique]
iny possible mais il a modelé qu'est ce
que tu veux tu retournes et à pal
je n'ai pas fini de la lyre tu m'embête
enlève ton ombre et je n'y vois plus
rien et pour t'éviter les coups de
soleil
j'aime le soleil qui m'embête
[Musique]
le recours à ce coup c'est vous la
question vous fait audi gentil de
barrios la hâte que ça va mal car tu as
mal au coeur je vais te faire une bonne
tisane
moi j'étais très jolie pitt tout rose
ma fille chez moi la paix vous est
insupportable
tu vois tu la balance lit trop vite
peut-être toi non c'est toi c'est
adéquat toi
[Musique]
alors ça m'a convié croyez vous qu'il y
ait deux pas plus qu'ils ne voteront pas
voter bien sûr photo
attention ils ont manqué
[Musique]